I've had a lot of mentors in my career
many of them were paid a few of them
were free the point of a good teacher is
that the student does pass the teacher I
see this thing that happens all the time
when you're a kid and you learn
arithmetic first you learn your numbers
and then you learn how to add you level
up and you learn how to multiply and
then you level up from there and you
learn algebra when you get to algebra
you don't think man my arithmetic
teacher is a idiot I can't believe they
didn't teach me this stuff it's like
dude you weren't ready and you had to
have the arithmetic in order to get to
the multiplication it's not that that
teacher was an idiot it's that that was
the sequence and so when you have a
first teacher that teaches you the
basics and you have a more advanced
teacher later it doesn't mean you should
[ __ ] on your first teacher it's like
that person got you ready to receive the
next thing earlier on my career I
definitely did the other way this guy
didn't know anything this guy is the guy
rather than seeing it like you would see
any other thing that you'd have in
school I've had the opportunity in the
you know the gift of being able to
Mentor whatever you want to say you know
provide advice counsel share my
experiences a lot of people hold me in a
regard and most people who are winners
are competitive it's just like who you
are right you want to win you to beat
everybody because that's that's part of
the competitive drive but I think
there's like a there's a comma there
that needs to get put in which is that
you have to accept two things one is
that you are going to die and no one is
going to remember like real real ten
thousand years from now no one's going
to remember at all number two is that
when you're at the end of your life the
people who are going to be your buyer
vets are not the people who you Vanquish
but the people that you helped I know
that I have passed a lot of the mentors
that I've had in my career in terms of
financials Etc earlier on used to think
that made me better than them as I've
had a couple more years and some more
more scars I've realized something
different which is that I was only able
to get better than them because they
gave me the Head Start step on my
shoulder you can reach that next Branch
I think I experience a lot of Joy
knowing that other people don't have to
suffer as much you know we're walking
around outside yesterday and someone's
like dude I did everything you have and
we're doing four million dollars a year
now like he was like emotional just
knowing that it's happening it makes
stomaching the hard times easier it
feels like it's not just me trying to do
this for myself it's me trying to do
this for a lot of people if I'm failing
over and over again at this thing I know
that once I figured out I'll be able to
help 100 people cheat code their way
through it and not spend five months
figuring something out or two years
figuring something out like I was stuck
at Mid 30 million for three years to
everyone watching they're like boo hoo
that's not the point is that there's
another guy who's going to get to that
point and he's going to move right past
it like in a blink of an eye because
I've had the right advice that I didn't
have and I think that if the mentees and
the mentors both see it that way then
the mentees will stop [ __ ] on the
mentors that help them and the mentors
will stop trying to hold back secrets
that have propelled them further because
the point is not that you're going to
beat everyone you're going to get really
old
and then you're gonna die as you're
getting older they're going to be people
who are younger who had a head start and
as long as the next guy honors the fact
that that guy died on the battlefield to
give him these lessons and come back and
they have to recognize that they're
going to die on the battlefield too for
the Next Generation to pass them they
have it easier than us
that's the point of progress and so
rather than lamenting that the Next
Generation has it easier I thought that
what we all say I want to make the world
a better place well that's what making
the world a better place looks like we
say that this is our mission with our
business we want to make the world a
better place we want to make an impact
and then when it actually happens we
resent the kids for the fact that they
didn't have it as hard as us that was
the point my point is not to beat the
progeny a point is to forge as far as I
can look back and be like hey watch out
for that hole watch out for that rock
keep going keep going because they move
through the path that we tread three
times faster than we did because we
already cleared all the trees they get
to the next non-clearing and they have
to start hacking away and hacking away
and hacking away to forge the next PATH
and then they become the mentors turn
around and the Next Generation moves six
times as fast to cover my distance and
their distance if you look at some of
the greatest success stories a lot of
them talk about their mentors Warren
Buffett had his mentor early on the
quick story on that was that he said
I'll work for you for free and Paul
Graham told him you're overpriced he was
the one who's going to be giving far
more to this relationship even if Warren
gave him his time he still was going to
to be on the losing side but he still
did it anyways because he recognized
that Warren had a gift Warren passed him
in his career you'll notice that Warren
isn't like man I'm so much better than
Paul Graham I passed that dude in my
like 40s he doesn't talk like that we
really do stand on the shoulders of the
Giants when I think about like the
gratitude that I have for the garyvee's
who is 12 years older than I am he's
forged so much of this path that like I
didn't have to think about how am I
going to create this whole thing it's
like he already had a blueprint and I
could just start laying that out
immediately execute there are guys who
we have in our portfolio right now who
are in their 20s who are making twice
when I was making at 30 but if they came
to me below and then now they're above
that was the point garyvee didn't have
Gary Vee to Mentor him on his career I
do right now we all do many of us will
pass Gary and I don't think Gary mines
there's a 20 year old it might be you
who's watching this and you've got me
that's the point I'm still going to be
hustling trying to beat you don't get me
wrong when I see guys who are in their
60s I'm like man by the time I'm 60 I'm
gonna be 10 times as wealthy as that 10
times the the real estate 10 times yeah
but if they had had themselves as
mentors they would too if your mentees
and the students that you have and the
people that you help and the people that
you teach don't move above you it means
that you're a bad teacher not a good one
the new definition of success of a
teacher is that the students surpass the
teacher and then get to the point where
they're both looking together with his
experience and his Raw Talent looking at
the new landscape saying all right what
do you think we should do if this video
changed your mind about some of the [ __ ]
talking that you've done to a teacher or
to a mentor who is earlier on in your
career shoot that guy a text and be like
hey like respect I appreciate you I
can't tell you one how much it means to
the mentor when they get that text and I
also think too it'll help you spit out
the poison that you had that wasn't real
it was only made up in your head I think
if you can do those things this video
would have been a success